an Arabic letters. It is
is not considered by many
Christians and Jews to be a
prophet. He is considered to be
a man who was mentioned in a
biblical context and this is
not the first of their menu
fabrications against prophets
and messengers. Many prophets
and messengers of Allah they
ascribe different
lies and fabrications to them
accusing them of atrocities
really and of these lies
is covering up their heinous
acts of disbelief in their own
prophets by claiming that these
men are not prophets or by
claiming that people who were
not prophets to be prophets.
For instance, they do not
believe that Job was a prophet.
They do not believe that Lot,
Lut, was a prophet. They did
not believe that David or
Solomon were prophets. but they
believe that Esther was a
prophet, a prophetess
Ayub Alaihi Salam is a prophet
of Allah. from the lineage of
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam or I
should say from the prodigy of
Ibrahim from the offspring of
Ibrahim. by way of is a prophet
[Silence]
Many things are mentioned with
regards to his story. The story
of his patience and the story
of his tribulation, mentioned
that family was killed This is
the pleasure of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala with and his patience
dare to try to take a yube off
of the path of righteousness.
and said, if you allow me to
afflict him, it will become
impatient.
It's mentioned that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala allowed
such affliction. So, Ayub fell
ill Children were killed in a
freak accident
lost his wealth, he lost his
livestock, he lost his status
socially
mentioned that He had Disease
inside of his body and outside
He remained in this state,
patient, and dutiful for a
number of years. The number of
years is unclear. It's not
explicitly mentioned. In the
Quran or authentic sunnah of
the prophet
mentioned that it was 18 years
less than this, more than this,
and these estimates are taken
from the estimates of the
people of the scripture. their
books And so, Ayub Alaihi Salam
was patient We have to be very
very prudent and careful and
dealing with the stories of the
prophets and messengers Because
unfortunately throughout time,
Many of the books of history
and books of Tefsir. Have been
infected with fabrications
against the prophets and
messengers and some of the
scholars of Islam, mention in
passing
from the people of the book
From the Torah, from the
Gospels, the from the book of
Dawood Alaihi Salam, etcetera.
ghastly heinous things have
been ascribed to prophets and
messengers. You have to
understand the history of
Tefsir. history of exegesis in
Islam.
FCA was essentially
science of the companions.
companions understood the Quran
because they spent time with
the prophet
after his death and of course,
there were elements of the
Quran that needed to be
explicitly mentioned and
explained. So, the prophet
explained them. The narrations
that explain explicitly this
verse means this are not very
many. They're few because it
was largely unnecessary.
and so The time of the
companions was spent with the
prophet
And the prophet through his
life's legacy and his life and
times explained the Quran
Either by action or by explicit
statements or what have you. In
the time of the the generation
that came after the companions
It became more crucial or
explicit statements to be made
about verses of the Quran and
what they mean. Because the
generation that came after the
companions was a generation
that did not spend time with
the prophet
and so, the companions we find
many more statements of the
companions saying, this verse
means this, this word means
this, etcetera. Because of the
necessity at the time.
Likewise, those who came after
the generation that came after
the companions. So, two
generations after the
companions. We have the
students of the companions
expounding on meanings of the
Quran even more. Because the
Muslims are coming from all
walks of life. They come from
different cultures. They come
from different backgrounds,
different languages. And the is
no longer as clear to them as
it was to the earlier
generations.
Many of the or all of the
narrations from the companions,
from the companion students
were collected by the scholars
of hadith and the scholars of
Tafsir, with chains of
narration. So, all of the
statements of even Abbas, all
of the statements of Abdullah
and Omar, Abdullah, Omar Abdul
Khatab, all of these scholars
of Tafseer, of the companions,
and of the Tabereen, Mujahid,
Said
[Silence]
sometimes fifteen, 20 people
would be in one chain of
narration and the books of
hadith that collected these
narrations were mainly, were
mainly preserved and so people
started to say, Al Bukhari
reported and and skipped the
chain of narration. In the
fifth century, after Hijla,
we're talking 500 years now,
Chains of narration were no
longer used as they were in the
earlier times. And so scholars
of Tafseer started to just
mention narrations without
chains of narration. and during
this time, when this shift
happened, this is when other
scholars who had good
intentions and others who may
not have had good intentions,
started to enter things into
the of the verses of the Quran
that had no business being
there. Mainly, from the books
of the people of the scripture.
From the books of the
Christians and the Jews. And we
know that there are lots of
fabrications in these books.
Fabrications are numerous.
These fabrications are even in
the most critical of verses in
their books that they base
their beliefs on and when this
happened, it could not be
undone When this kind of
explosion of of writing
happened because it so happens
that at that same time, the
fourth, fifth, sixth, seventh
century after Hijrah, this is
when there was an intellectual,
literate, literate, an
explosion of of literature from
the scholars of Tafseer and
from scholars hadith and
because the Muslims became very
wealthy and many kings,
sultans, and so forth, they
would have scholars working
full time for them, paid. All
they had to do was spend their
time writing books. and so,
many books were written and
during this era, many
fabrications were entered in to
the books of Tafsir, history
books, books on history,
Tafsir, Firk, etcetera. This
caused a lot of problems
because later, when it was no
longer scholars reading these
books who knew what the other
scholars meant when it was the
layperson and regular people
now starting to become
literates and reading books
that they shouldn't be reading
yet they started to pick these
things up and assume that
everything that the scholar
wrote was authentic. and this
entered many fabrications into
thee, into the mind, into the
Muslim mind And we have been
recovering ever since. We will
continue inshallah tomorrow.